[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
careful boy hey
we got sway here today again what's up
swag hello hello thanks for having me
what's your last name tran
now
you see your face bro
it's wing
wing that's how you really pronounce it
it's not nuan
when right nagayan
your last name tran anthony oh you know
my last name dog i know but i wanted to
be tran
how did they get new yen from
i heard it was a king
yeah um the
wind dynasty the wind dynasty yeah they
he made like everyone change their last
name or and if they didn't they're
that's correct that's why there's so
many of yes that's why that's why is it
technically n g u
y y e n the same as
h-y-u-n-h is that the same last name no
you're saying h-u-y-n-h win yeah no no
it's different oh when it's actually my
mom's name oh really yeah oh
damn
what's what's inside here about a book
yeah so i just got a book deal with um
simon and schuster i [ __ ] hate you
why
the [ __ ] [ __ ] you get is [ __ ] oh
all right so this let me before you guys
you guys got a new place right this is
what rick was telling me so blame him if
you hate his ass
before she got this new place
and then she was like
i need to
get some interior design and some [ __ ]
and like and get hook it up for some
furniture so you know rick's like okay
let's figure out what the budget is and
then bam
[ __ ] furniture sponsorship comes out
of nowhere and they just hook your whole
[ __ ] up and they came and designed it
you know what's so crazy about that it's
supposed to be like a show right like a
makeover show they were in the middle
filming it something went down i didn't
want to really get into it but something
went down production ended up canceling
the show but i was still able to keep
the furniture and the money on top of
that so i'm like i don't even have to do
anything
literally they just gave you [ __ ]
and interior design toy's just a win
she's just a winner because that's even
crazier than the furniture
because when the interior interior
designer touches your place it boom next
level right so that to me is even
crazier than the furniture because we
could all go out and buy whatever we
want but the fact that they put
something together and go
i can't even get a walmart sponsorship i
know like i can understand the interior
design in the furniture because they've
already done that stuff but it's like
you got to keep the money as well that's
pretty cool because already signed oh
you know what the
converts extremely well because we sent
over a mushroom care for toy and
although it is my company she
outperforms me on my own product oh [ __ ]
thank you thank you that's what it is
i've already told you this before but
it's easy to sell a good product oh
thank you thank you thank you thank you
it works out probably because your fan
base
watches you exactly for that reason yes
like my family
they don't watch me for mushroom growing
and cooking what they watch me for is
they're hoping that i will one day fail
and cry about it and talk publicly about
it what a great family yeah they're
waiting for that moment
i think they all joined my instagram
like they followed me because they're
like oh who's this disabled guy trying
to make it in entertainment who's this
disney who's this mentally disabled
human they're like oh satisfied for the
last eight years
[Laughter]
so now you got this [ __ ] book thing
what the hell dude so yeah what is this
is it a cookbook yeah it's a cookbook so
um
to get a cookbook you kind of have to
like form like a basic idea of like what
you want like how the format's gonna be
um and all of that stuff and you submit
it to the publisher and then they review
it they see if they like it and they
offer you
some um they offer you a deal badass
paper yeah
she doesn't cuss in her videos either
that's why that's why we failed
damn that's hard cuss i mean i it's not
really what happens if you started
cussing say something right now i don't
think there's an effect
right now or something some real mean
no i'm not a cuss anymore
stop cussing the next video right all
right till the next video see we need to
take notes from twig because we've been
on longer and we should be more
successful but we're not
you are though one no we when we find
this book where can i find this oh no
well it's not out yet like
i have a whole year to work on it they
give you a year yeah do they pay you and
say just go to work this is a legit
book deal like
publisher
search of simon schuster how did how did
this come about like did they approach
you you've been pitching like how does
that work
working with a literary agent to work
how do you even find a [ __ ]
named literary agent no cuz i'm trying
to make an erotic novel but i don't know
anybody that wants to sponsor me but
yeah how did you find the literary
because honestly i've been looking for a
literary agent too i don't even know how
to find one um it's honestly through my
manager like i i just like how you find
a manager
i tell him like all my goals that i have
in the beginning when i signed with him
he sat me down he's like what are the
some of your goals that you have i just
wrote down like my biggest like most i
guess unreasonable goal and i'm just
like this is unattainable at the time
and i was like this is what i want to do
and he's like okay
and then actually does we had like three
managers that we had to fire because
they didn't work we never had any sit
downs like that yeah yeah they told us
we had a network that was like give me
your list of goals and then they [ __ ]
just took our money yeah
yeah
yeah shout out to the rn rhm team like
they do work damn see we work with the
wrong people they brought in a lit agent
they brought in the agent and then i was
working on like the i guess like the
idea of the book and then out of nowhere
um the publisher simon schuster they
reached out to me that an editor that
reached out to me and he was like like i
don't know if you're looking to do a
cookbook but we'd love to sign you
and then here we are
wow that's amazing man is it vietnamese
food of course
of course it's vietnamese food but it's
more than like they're just they're
looking for a different type of cookbook
because they love the fact that like i
do like actual cooking and then they i'm
also like into fashion and all of that
stuff so they want like a different take
on a cookbook like a lifestyle cooking
yeah like there's with swag
it's like a noodle shop and a sweatshop
put together it's like let me let me
make a skirt and some fur at the same
time the idea yeah
like a skirt steak with a schoolgirl
skirt it'll be kind of like um you know
those shoe books like those like
hypebeast um like fashion books it will
kind of be like that format but with
recipes and food
that's so [ __ ] cool dude that's me
the first of its kind the hell if it's
your brand too yeah that's dope and it's
the fact that like they really enjoy
like just me as a whole like as a
creator um
they're like yeah just we trust you we
trust your vision so i was like okay
cool
that's
fine with me when is rick gonna be in it
he's gonna be a picture of him probably
lucky breaks in the background just with
a bowl of foam
i definitely want to go to vietnam to
take photos for the book though i think
that would be really cool they got that
kind of budget it's either that or a
little psychonaut so it wasn't like like
200 bucks or 250. oh it's like
it's a it's a book deal
what does that mean
we don't know what that means a major
book deal i hate myself
i don't even know what major book deal
means
my peasant ass never touched such a
thing
she's [ __ ] walking on red carpet you
know what happened i don't have any red
carpets i've been on [ __ ] nine only
gray and [ __ ] this is what happened okay
jk news is like the asian immigrant that
came to america and opened up a liquor
store in the ghetto yep and we stayed
there
is like that but turned it into 7-eleven
and sold it to all the indians [ __ ]
family and [ __ ] dude that's worldwide
[ __ ] man
i love being here
[Laughter]
doesn't it make you feel great that
you're surrounded by people that are
going someplace like the guests
always progressive over here bring on
people that are like man i used to look
up to you guys but we certainly and i
surpassed the [ __ ] out of you today you
motivate us well honestly like like i
said earlier to you guys i'd rather put
in 100 hours of work a week and then
retire by 30 than work 40 hours a week
for the rest of my life yeah but that's
we have that mentality but we're still
stuck 40 we're 40 hours plus a week and
we're living we're going to start
working and we're not going to stop
working we're still going to retire when
i'm 70. yeah because we want that life
but we suck at it
[Laughter]
um so
when is this book coming out then well i
have a whole year to work on it so i
guess we're looking at like
um
fall of 2023
what happens if you deliver
too early because i think i would say
you have great work ethics and you might
finish it too early because you're so
excited do they go let's release
it just has to be that day oh it's part
of their plan well no i i don't think so
because i want to i want to utilize all
that that time since it's like a my
first ever book like a really good job
yeah what if you what if you're like
super duper lazy and then you don't even
[ __ ] do it what happens what do you
get in trouble um
yeah
but i feel like i uh i could hire a team
to like just also do that work too next
level i know see i hired a team but i
got this [ __ ] and this [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] i realize i don't need to be in
charge of everything like i don't need
to take photos like i can hire somebody
to do that for me i don't i can hire a
ghostwriter i can like there are so many
tasks that i can delegate so i'm just
like okay like
i just want to make sure that my vision
is on track like that's that's my job
michael man why don't you [ __ ] teach
us this [ __ ] dude i hired for you i
don't i don't know [ __ ] wasting all
this money
seriously so i think that's really
obviously [ __ ] awesome
congratulations thank you you're getting
a book deal like that you said that you
were you were putting down with your
manager some just your wildest dreams
and like you know maybe a book deal was
like one of those what else is on that
okay so like right now i've
like throughout this whole year i feel
like my career has been like crazy
but like
rubbing it
he's gonna pull his eyelids off
[Laughter]
every time i reach a goal i'm just like
okay next goal yeah and right now my
next goal really realistically is to
open up a restaurant in vietnam so i can
provide jobs for my family over there
wow
that's [ __ ] cool
is it like saigon or hanoi or what
that sounds familiar is it like south of
saigon yeah it is it's south of saigon
is that because your family
is unhirable they don't have they need
you no like they're they're good but
it's just like we don't have anything
that's our own and we don't have
anything that we're in charge of and
like my cousins are having babies over
there so i want them to have something
like that and i want to be a part of
that well what if they're like part of
management and stuff like that and then
i can hire my staff i can hire people
come on now i know the owner of 24. why
so gangster like that
and the um and the in the the that big
coffee one highland yeah okay yeah
what's up i'll introduce you okay yeah
they're real
and they also own all the um hard rock
cafes out there too
yeah
that's they're pretty cool finally met
them once i wouldn't call them homies so
if they [ __ ] you over it's not my fault
i'll introduce you how did you do shoot
okay hey i don't know anything about
them but we talk on whatsapp we talk
about all right and we hung out but
that's all i'm gonna say gotcha does
your t-shirt say calabasas it does it
does say calabasas well he's from
calabasas no i'm not i'm not from
calabasas
okay calabasas calabasas mike that's
what we call gotcha quarter ranch so
close by but not quite the same that's
like
20 minutes probably 30 minutes 30
minutes that place is developing like a
[ __ ] yeah it's this guy it is
were you looking in that place to move
out too no like uh one of the most
famous builders toll brothers they're
crushing it over there they have like
some some sick uh we're talking about
some dad [ __ ] man hello
[Music]
[Laughter]
this isn't las vegas okay you can't put
a casino anywhere you want tall brothers
go back to the vietnam
well i did i went back like every single
year before the pandemic oh i went right
2019 was my first time going there i
love it so much i love it yeah i want to
go cause the uh i don't know if i told
you last time you're here but what blew
my mind was i was out there for like a
month and i didn't eat the same dish
twice ever like every day was something
different
like for breakfast lunch and dinner
different food and i was just mind blown
at the variety like i didn't i didn't
even see that much [ __ ] on a vietnamese
restaurant yeah yeah there's so much
food over there it's crazy and like if
you go to different regions there's
always something new to try mm-hmm
what's the next thing for you here i
know the book deals obviously like you
got that
well you're working on that the whole
year what's like the next thing you're
working on right now though um i love
doing pop-ups i love doing dinners so i
think i'm just um gonna focus on that
because
i mean like i love doing content videos
but like being able to like feed people
in real life and like being in the
kitchen and all that stuff is so
fulfilling
what do you mean when you say i love
doing dinners
like i love serving like i love cooking
for people
like private dinners and events and like
stuff like that you ever do private like
who's somebody interesting that you did
a private dinner for well yesterday i
just did a private dinner for hate is a
virus oh for the whole organization the
gala how many people made like pastries
in the shape of coven and stuff or yes
exactly did you that's what it yeah
that's what [ __ ] lioness
cake
cake
i think the vaccine inside weren't you
at an ada rising and boozing out there
too no it was complex complex con
yeah styling food duh let's see like
that's how you build the brand yeah yeah
that's really cool
so i i have a question so you um you
told your manager that you wanted to
eventually have a book and then the
publisher contacted you like what was
that meeting like when you went to
because you flew to new york is what you
said right they had this meeting yeah
well i had a meeting um
every time i hear this story it just
adds a zero to the deal
oh [ __ ] new york damn a year
oh shoot the [ __ ] you try our team
it's a ten figure deal drop my eyelids
again
you should just man why did you want to
do
[ __ ] comedy business partner you
could have told me at any time yo we
should do [ __ ] fabrics
fabrics
i'm just saying dude
if we stab into the dark stop doing
comedy i know dude we could have done
anything but comedy makes the least
[ __ ] money it really did try dancing
oh [ __ ] you got a [ __ ] empire bro we
had studios in china and [ __ ] we don't
got studios nowhere besides here
chefs cooks the restaurant industry we
don't make a lot of money so i think
this is just like tell that to gordon
ramsay okay well david one percenter
literally literally literally i can name
like 10 famous chefs right now okay
those are famous shout outs but think
about all the other people that aren't
famous i can't even name 10 famous
comedian youtubers
yeah i bet you could i bet you could
joe
everyone else is [ __ ] broke now
i don't know
everyone spent all their money
yeah jk tim and david that's it
everyone else is whack
that that's 40 4 out of 10 right there
yeah
where the [ __ ] is ray william johnson i
don't know where the [ __ ] he is he
cashed out yeah he's number one at one
point i don't know where did they all
just cash out that's probably why yeah
cause everyone becomes successful like
tway here and then they go you know what
it's time to just relax in my nice house
and then we have to keep working because
we blew our money on stupid [ __ ] what
was the dumbest thing yeah i was gonna
ask that each other
that was like the dumbest thing
me yeah
i just stupid he's like reckless
there was that one year we spent
probably like 70 g's on guns
that ain't dumb maybe they're worth more
now though so they're like an investment
because yeah that's pretty tight
all the guns i sold they sold for a
profit but i only made like 20 or 30
above but still it's a profit
still the plus buy 70 g's get 70 g's and
20.
i made a japanese tea room a custom
japanese tea room for 20 grand oh yeah i
forgot about that do you remember that
what do you mean you bought that at the
office no he custom built it in his
office at their office carpenter that's
some [ __ ] i would do i love that [ __ ]
that's pretty now it's in my friend's
house it's traditional japanese
carpentry like nail this carpentry
though it was sick toy's gonna make five
of them for her house because she can
afford it good to know that it's 20 g's
and we bought a samurai we spent 10 g's
on the samurai suit yeah oh my god but
the samurai suit and the case we got it
custom made the case it was like three
grand itself why did you do that that's
just pretty cool though it is really
it's called new money you know
it's called new money
i think we spent like [ __ ] half a
mill plus on the other office that it's
just just building it just building it
and then what what happened to it
started from the bottom we still here
start from the bottom we came back
we have [ __ ] like 40 oh how many of
those lights do we have professional ass
lights that [ __ ] go like this and
[ __ ] got like 40 of them yeah there's 40
of them and then each one was like about
the sound stage 1000 plus dollars
yeah and obviously when you buy it new
it's really expensive but when you sell
it it's like nowhere close and now we
still we still pay for a storage to
store all that [ __ ] right it's all gone
no it's done that's
i know somebody that wants to i thought
we have 40 of those [ __ ] lights
they've been giving them away no no they
all got sold to random people so i just
have petty cash that i'm just collecting
oh
oh that's amazing did you handle the
sell out of this because i got a bunch
of extra stuff i need to sell too from
our old studio i i don't i don't know if
i can help you with that unfortunately
i don't know yes
[ __ ] ton of mirrors i don't know what to
do
you should put them on offer a valuable
dude yeah they're a thousand dollars
each plus how many of them are awesome i
still got like 15. okay sit on the gold
mine come to another person who wants to
start a dance studio yeah i ain't trying
to like hook another dance studio
i'll [ __ ] make them yeah a gym
shelter industry
picture of them send it to me photos why
is so salty because that's how you stay
up you keep others down that's right you
know send me a picture and support all
the other cookbooks out there vietnamese
swag style what's up
yes
i might be the seller for you oh watch
out about it yeah i got a bunch of [ __ ]
that sent it to me this has just become
a jk meeting
facebook like 26. you saw this i saw
this for you
[Music]
you